I just can't believe car 3 is finally
here I know the movie has been waiting
for my whole life
after the genius that was cars to Pixar
finally answered my 417 letters with a
new car three movie you only wrote 417
tried 9500 get it 95 the number of the
greatest Pixar character of all time
Lightning McQueen
well cars 3 is a movie and it's actually
in theaters and it's a new Pixar film
and if you didn't realize I really am
NOT a fan of the car series thought one
was alright thought 2 was probably the
worst Pixar movie ever made they made
the choice to basically make mater the
most annoying character and Pixar
history the essential lead of that movie
and I walked out so disappointed and
angry and they made another one guys the
trailers for Kars 3 however got my
attention because they seem to be
suggesting that there was going to be a
change in the creative outlook of this
series that it would be taken from a
more serious direction that they would
go back to the roots so to speak of the
Cars franchise which is about racing and
in this case they actually do go back to
the roots of this franchise which is the
first Cars movie which was ok so the
third ones also ok but hey they went
back to their roots
so Lightning McQueen voiced by Owen
Wilson is getting older and he's
starting to lose races to new blood a
new racer on the scene named storm has
all of the current modern-day technology
and updates so McQueen goes on a search
for himself and tries to get back to his
old ways and learn how to be a better
racer with a new trainer named Cruz
which is a good idea because I think
Lightning McQueen is one of the dullest
characters and Pixar as a library so it
was good to take his story and make it
more of an underdog film which is what
we get here essentially it's about him
training to get faster and faster to
hopefully beat storm this new racer
that's kind of pompous and rude the
first half of this movie was painfully
dull even the kids sitting next to me
kept asking his parents questions and
they weren't like questions necessarily
about the movie you just feel like I'm
tired I'm thirsty
I'm hungry dad my shoe fell off
hey this tall giant man sitting next to
me keeps sighing really loudly the first
half has so many jokes that fall
completely flat and a lot of this first
half
almost feels like Pixar trying to make
an apology for cars too because they
take the character of mater they push
him far to the background he's in a few
scenes for his fans you know and there
are scenes where McQueen is talking
about how he has to make himself better
than he used to be he has to upgrade
himself he has to make himself faster
and stronger and you're like yeah I
think they're saying that about the cars
franchise to buy this first half is so
boring
where the film picks up considerably and
gets much better is when McQueen goes
out on the road and trains with crews
who's a really good new character and
probably my favorite character in the
movie they race on sandy beaches they go
to a demolition derby and McQueen really
tries to search inside himself and
figure out what made him want to be a
racer in the first place and this is
where the film gets a lot better in the
second half of this movie I actually
quite enjoyed it's just that that first
half is such a dull sinking weight of a
movie the second half really helps pick
it up but in the end it still levels out
to be an OK experience it's a lot better
than Cars 2 and even though I'm not a
huge fan of the first one I would say
it's close to being on par with that and
I haven't seen it in years I would have
to re-watch it I've only seen it one
time when it first came out but I seem
to remember having a fairly similar
experience with that film that I did
with this one it's a lot better as I
said than - there's a good message here
it gets surprisingly touching towards
the end and there's a decision that even
though I saw it coming a mile away
come I'll await car puns all over the
place that first half really dragged you
know nothing dragged my god even though
it was predictable it was surprisingly
touching the direction the third act
takes I think kids will have fun with it
and adults will be able to sit through
this one a lot better than - it's still
like a Cars movie again like it really
isn't like this direction changing shift
that the marketing made me think it was
I'm going to give car 3 a C+
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to my next film
series I've just completed my
transformer series leading up to the
last night my next one is going to be
Christopher Nolan movies I haven't
reviewed a lot of people requested this
and I would like to do that for you guys
it was already what I was going to do I
actually made a list of all of my series
for the rest of the year like back in
January so I'm excited to do this I'm
really excited to bring my Nolan reviews
to you guys and the first one is going
to be his very first film following to
look forward to that this weekend guys
you are the best thank you very much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]